and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is Joshua Fields
Milburn and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and
together we're the minimalist today
we're gonna talk about Fame we're gonna
talk about notoriety we're gonna talk
about the difference between being
famous and being well-known and we're
gonna talk about the upsides and
downsides of stardom with today's guest
jennette mccurdy is here an actual
famous person I am thanks so much for
being here I think you're probably the
most famous person that's been on our
podcast so far yeah well I guess it
depends on who yes crazy so you probably
know Jeanette from icarly Sam McHale
she's she's an actress she is a singer
writer producer director we'll talk
about a lot of that I also want to talk
about how we first met but first just a
quick update for our audience we're
getting ready to go on tour the the
Lesko store yes and we're gonna be in
eight cities US and in Canada and we had
a bit of a small problem with the venue
so I just want to give people an update
here all of the events are now teenager
friendly we had a bit of a problem
there were like three or four of the
venues where I was like you know
eighteen or twenty-one and so we had to
go back to the venue's and sort of work
it out with each of them and and so now
every venue is teenager friendly if you
want to check out the city that we're
gonna be in closest to you head on over
to the minimalists column slash tour
alright Jeanette we met I was walking
through a parking lot and you were
shouting on a window at me I was a movie
and I had literally just been listening
to your podcast like ten minutes before
I pulled it well I was with my boyfriend
he pulled up and it was the meeting you
was there was nothing I was more
invested in at that time of my life then
your guys podcast like it was my life it
was the you know when you get obsessed
with a thing and it's like the thing
that dictates every decision that you
make that's where I was I was listening
to just insane amounts of your progress
so then to see you walk past there was a
second where I was like was it was it
really him like I couldn't even believe
it and I think I just like shouted you
her name out the window or some
embarrassing but then you were so nice
you like weren't taken off guard you
were you know just easygoing well I get
recognized occasionally but nowhere near
the level that you do and so I want to
talk about that today because there are
sort of these these varying levels and
you had to deal with it from a very
young age and so we're gonna we're gonna
dive into that but it's as you know it's
a very listener driven show so I thought
maybe what we could do is we start the
conversation by answering some questions
and so we have a question here from
Lauren in Tampa Florida
hi this is Lauren calling from Tampa
Florida it seems that in our society we
enjoy seeing people succeed and people
of course love to share their successes
on social media but why is it that we
also get so much satisfaction from
seeing people fail so Janette you we I
think this is true you you have people
who are really rooting for you they want
you to succeed they want to watch
whatever you're doing next but there are
also other people who who seems like no
matter what you do you can never do
right and in their eyes why do we think
that is it's it's an interesting area
because I think like I can speak I guess
specifically to the kind of like child
stardom teenage stardom thing
because I feel like that's what people
are even more interest like people are
even more interested in seeing a former
child star fail right like there's like
Lindsay Lohan Britney Spears
I mean Macaulay Culkin Justin Bieber
even there it's like there's the the
idea of pulling down their narrative and
making them into this crazy like men
person having a mental breakdown I don't
I don't understand the fascination with
it I wish that wasn't the case I think
it perpetuates whoever's experiencing
probably some real mental health
struggles it makes it worse for them I
wish that society didn't do that to
people it bothers me so much god it
bothers me so much I don't know what
needs to change or how it can change I
was actually watching a documentary on
Lindsay Lohan the other day
and a paparazzi dude was interview he
was like somebody was following him and
he's like I don't get why she doesn't
like me I don't get why she doesn't want
to smile for the camera like shouldn't
she love this I'm getting her attention
shouldn't she love this no you're
chasing her down like you're following
her why would she love it it doesn't
make any sense to me you know what I
think it makes sense to him because
that's what he wants he wants someone to
he wants that level of attention or at
least let me rephrase that that's what
he thinks
he wants until he gets it now Ryan and I
have this weird sort of level of we're
not famous but we are well-known enough
that occasionally people recognize us oh
but I get recognized all the time when
I'm with Josh how much people like like
is it normal for people to shout out
their windows how often does this happen
yeah I mean five six times a day maybe
but it's not it's not enough where it's
like if I'm walking through a crowd it's
one out of 50 people maybe and so like
it's not but you never know who that one
out of 50 people are right and if it's
one out of 50 people who say something
then it's what another four or five who
don't say something but still it's the
vast vast majority have no idea who we
are and I'm completely contented with
that but there is a there's a level and
it's sort of like it's sort of like
grains of sand like how many grains of
sand make a beach right like at some
point there's a level where it is a
beach but you know one grain of sand is
not a beach like what is the level of
notoriety that makes a person famous I
don't know but from a very young age you
had to deal with with being recognized
and and and how are you how did you deal
with that early on it was not easy I
think some people are naturally just
kind of good at Fame like maybe their
personality type or history I'm not sure
what makes a person good at fame but I
was I felt incredibly anxious like there
is there was a time now it's totally
it's completely manageable it's not
difficult at all it doesn't feel like a
hindrance on my life but there is a time
from probably 14 years old to 22
where I couldn't leave the house without
you know without paparazzi without just
hordes of people anywhere I went in a
grocery store or you know wherever and I
I think it made life so difficult I mean
I I don't think young people should be
allowed to be famous like there's
somebody who could come in and say no
they can't this is they're not mentally
capable of handling this I think that
should happen and because it's just you
know the thing with former child stars
having breakdowns makes so much sense to
me because I think the world that your
throat thrust into kind of like puts you
right in line to have a breakdown you
know it's it's so abnormal to have
people follow you around and what you're
want to capture the moment with you but
then at some point it becomes normal to
you even though it's still a very
abnormal thing and I think when it
becomes normal especially to a kid man
you were setting that person up for
failure as an adult because then there's
one of my favorite lines from a book
called freedom by Jonathan Franzen I
don't know if you read it but one of the
characters is a musician and he's famous
and he talks about Fame being the thing
that he never want that he doesn't want
but that also doesn't want to live
without and it's like this weird sort of
thing where like you you don't want that
but also at the same time if he were to
lose it he would maybe lose a part of
his identity in a way your identity
might get wrapped especially as a kid
get wrapped and gets wrapped up into
that Who I am as a person is this this
famous entity maybe so I always saw it
like I don't relate to that I definitely
just did not want to be famous I didn't
I didn't like the experience and I
couldn't wait til I could just like you
know put that aside but yeah I wonder
what he was finding like what he was
latching on to in the fame I guess the
identity thing makes sense like
particularly for actors maybe there's
there's a bit of an identity crisis with
being famous because you're famous or
something that's not you like maybe it's
easier for Oprah or somebody who's like
doing something they're proud of and
it's them and
you know or assume she's proud of hope
she's proud of what she's done but I
think if it's acting it's sort of like
you're known for this thing that's not
even you so you know who am i underneath
that and would I be famous if it were
just me my characters the famous thing
all the time and with us it's similar
it's never very rarely it's like hey
Josh hey Ryan its hey minimal is dude
when I get a lot of time to like are you
one of the minimalize so I'm like yeah
they're like I don't know which one you
are you know I think the the thing with
the line you were quoting from freedom
is that we all need some significance in
life yeah so Fame I think will certainly
give you that feeling of significance in
people's lives so maybe that's what he's
trying to hold on to is that that
significance so maybe you know the
answer to like that that whole that
sentence that you recording there was
you know find a way to be significant in
a meaningful way and maybe that's maybe
it's well the significance thing is also
what Lauren's question is talking about
here why do people tell other people
down because they want to feel it's so
common there's a shot schadenfreude is
the word like it cuz it's such a common
thing right I think I think right I
think one of the reasons why people like
to see people fail is because they will
see someone like a child actor for
example and how good they are at their
craft how happy they are how they have
the the rich and you know famous
lifestyle but then when they fail they
can say to themselves oh yeah I knew it
wasn't that good
I knew it cuz like a piece of them want
that but then when they see someone fail
they're like oh maybe oh yeah I really
didn't want that because it's it's it's
not all that it's cracked up to be
the other thing too I think is it also
gives people permission to not start
down a certain Road
see that's why not I never even started
to go down that road of famous because
that's where always gets you it's like
this I would have been a great actor but
that's why I decided not to do it
exactly it's like this affirmation or
something where it is you know gets
permission to people to yeah to never
see even start on a journey they sit
they say there are two ways to build you
have the tallest building in town one is
to build it right which is much harder
to become an actor and a cactus your
craft and
every day or become a writer or you know
whatever you want to do creatively it's
much easier to tear everyone else's
building down I think that's one of the
other reasons that we get so addicted to
to tear in other people's buildings down
or the reputation down it's the easiest
way for us to feel significant it's very
easy even now for me to be snarky and be
like ah you know look at that you know I
can't believe what that person is
wearing or doing or whatever because in
that moment it gives me this burst of
significance but there's nothing really
meaningful to it absolutely it's really
a projection I think one other side to
to the the quote from freedom that and
now I feel like I'm focusing on sort of
more that downsides of Fame so I'll try
and see it from a more balanced
viewpoint hopefully at some point during
the podcast but I something that people
I don't think consider with like trial
stardom is how you're famous for like
imagine being famous for your middle
school band that's what it's like to be
famous from a Nickelodeon show you know
naming like imagine if people were just
for the rest of your life like oh my god
that bass line in that song my crush was
so good and you're like oh my god I
wrote that when I was 11 this is so
embarrassing and that's sort of just
what you're always dealing with and it
feels like oh yeah just it feels very I
could see where it would like keep you
stuck in the past - yeah we're like yeah
I mean that's and you see that happen a
lot I mean we were kind of talking about
this yesterday when we're recording with
Peter about how you know you'll have an
artist to come out and put out an album
that's amazing and then they try to do
something different but then people just
want to latch onto that first album they
don't want to like give the second album
a chance sometimes they wanted James
Gandolfini to always be Tony Soprano
right and it's like no matter what a
role he does you're like you're going to
watch Tony Soprano play to play a
general in the military or whatever yeah
and what was fascinating about about
what you're saying there is I think I'm
thinking about the story from you know
Vanessa Carlton the the singer she wrote
her biggest hit when she was 16 years
old and it's a thousand miles right and
I've seen her in concert a few times we
have a friend who plays violin for her
who we've been on tour with and
shout-out to Sky Steel dude but anyway
she wrote that song she was 16 and I
think she had a sort of adversarial
relationship with that song for probably
about a decade because it was like I
wrote this thing and this is what I'm
known for this is what you showed up to
watch it's the reason you all are here
but like I'm so much more than this song
but then she sort of formed a date on
with it by the time she was 30 and
realized like wow this song has afforded
me this amazing career that's allowed me
to expand beyond this sort of pop piano
song and I should actually be grateful
for it and now there's this weird thing
where she does it at her concerts now
and she's you can tell she's actually
grateful for the song she doesn't
identify with it necessarily anymore but
it's given her this opportunity to
continue to play music today well into
her thirties and you can feel that
difference in how she performs it now
yeah that's really cool yeah and so I
think maybe there's this this this
period where yes being known for your
your eighth grade your junior high times
like I could see where I would be like
when I'm not that person anymore not
even close to that person anymore
but maybe it's also a springboard for
being a better version of myself now and
I don't know maybe it's sort of a
maturation although I you've I'm sure
you've seen it sort of maturation what
you're doing because you're writing and
directing now which is much different
from what you were doing as a teenager
yeah well I guess now has I'm thinking
about it like I wrote this article about
eating disorders in my history with
eating disorders and when people
approached me about that which is you
know having quite often since since it
came out I
it's a totally different reaction that I
have I feel so much more connected to
the person who's talking to me usually
they've had struggles with eating
disorders themselves and I feel like I'm
able to talk to them and I think that's
a thing that I felt like was really
missing from maybe the past where when
people would just kind of you know
scream at me from afar or you know just
take us want to take a selfie real quick
it's like it's a different level of bond
that I feel with the people who read
that and I'm not sure and I'm not sure I
would I would feel
as positively as I feel now if it
weren't for kind of putting my own stuff
out there and having people connect with
that they're connecting with you now
instead of a a fictional character yeah
instead of a character yeah well Lauren
I'm gonna send you a copy so you talked
about what you talked about a few things
here but relationships is one thing
because that I would really like to dive
deep into we don't have time to do it
right now so I'm gonna send you a copy
of our book minimalism live a meaningful
life there is a chapter in there about
relationships and really identifying the
people in your life that aren't toxic
relationship because if you have people
in your life who are trying to tear you
down whether you're famous or not that's
not a recipe for for success so
reprioritizing your relationships is
something that I found to be really
important in my own life
surrounding myself with people who are
supportive but also who share similar
values to me so I think you'll enjoy a
copy of minimalism live a meaningful
life shot if you could reach out to
Hearst under the audiobook version or if
you want the book book or the e-book
we'll send those to you as well also
since you're in Tampa
you know we own a coffee shop down well
it's in st. P so it's in the Tampa Bay
area that is the best coffee in the
Tampa Bay area it is definitely the best
call and and I know I mean we are biased
yeah we have very little to do with the
fact that it's the best call it is true
Barrett and I Ryan you were just down
there and
serving food recently I tasted
everything on the menu and our chef is
killing it like it is unbelievable yes
so good semantic coffee Lauren I'm gonna
send you in to bandit coffee we'll give
you a bag of coffee and a free drink and
a free meal if you want that as well
Sean if you could send that to her as
well maybe I'll just give her a gift
card from from bandit that would be
great
bandit coffee Co is the website if
anyone is interested oh and we have the
minimalist choice coffee now to the
minimalist stock coffee is the website
for that we have another question here
from Chris in Minneapolis hey this is
Chris in Minneapolis I came across
someone who was tweeting some pretty
racist things one time and I did a quick
click through his Twitter in case I
reversed evolution of a normal Twitter
user to have a racist supremacist I
guess so I just tweeted in a rental that
was pretty easy for internet that was
actually actually had
yes kind of like okay you're not
anonymous and once I tweeted in that you
know this Twitter came down and his
website came down and so I hope you know
he's changed but you know when people
actually have to be out in public they
probably would act differently that kind
of a anonymous so I would say the good
thing about being frame is that you have
influence but also if you've been trying
to negatively influence people in a
harmful way that can do a lot of damage
so yeah let's talk about the the good
thing about Fame or or being well-known
and I tend to agree with what Chris is
saying here you do have some influence
what's the spider-man lion Ryan Oh with
great responds great responsibility yeah
I think that that's true unfortunately
it's often squandered that that great
power is squandered well it's
interesting too cuz like I I think I
would start to get a little political
especially like back in 2016 but I I
have since like stuff only did that for
a little bit and I realized there like
there are certain things oh I don't want
to touch on because it's so divisive but
in the same token we could do things
like campaigns for charity water and we
can you know do some some philanthropic
things with that influence yeah so so
that's actually a really good example so
just last Friday I met with some folks
from uplift which is this organization
here in in Hollywood that helps children
families basically from very similar
upbringings to what you and I have or
there's a lot of drug and substance
abuse in the house and and and helps the
children in those households without
prying them away from the family sort of
retrains the family in a way and so Ryan
and I have done a lot of things that are
with charity or philanthropic and the
only reason we've been able to do that
to the scale that we have is because we
do have some influence so it's not just
the two of us doing it it's bringing
other people into the fold and
encouraging them to contribute that's
using it responsibly I do agree that
sometimes it makes sense to get involved
politically but I I think it only makes
sense in the traditional sense
the word politics from the Latin root
means the affairs of the city and if
we're talking about the affairs of the
populace then yeah to get involved
politically sounds great but if we're
trying to yell at people on Twitter
because we don't like the D or the R in
front of their name I don't find that to
be particularly useful or helpful often
it's very cynical but also it seems that
it gets in the way of what else we're
trying to do if you and I were to go out
there and either yell about Trump or
support Trump or vice versa for the
other side it it it would probably get
in the way of a message that is actually
helping people I think yeah it might be
a little disingenuous to like to Chris's
point like I wouldn't be yelling about
the deer they are to anyone on the
street and I you know what I'm saying
it's like and it's I think it's
important to note too late social media
we have to we have to realize that it is
a very fake world like it's my social
media self even me like yeah there's
these cool moments of me snowboarding
and some trips that I've been on but it
doesn't really express my entire life
but unfortunately sometimes like we look
at social media and we try to mimic like
a person's life like that's it's like
running after the sunset like you're
never gonna catch it it's but you can
see it but you're never actually gonna
get there so you've had some some
interactions on on social media and I'm
sure that it's it's difficult to keep up
with that we call a Twitter stream for a
reason you can't take it all in right
you can sort of dip your toe in the
water yeah I kind of I stopped social
media a few years ago like I completely
deleted all my tweets and I signed off
of Instagram I stopped using Facebook
for about a year and a half just cuz I
needed to focus on my mental health and
and you know working through eating
disorders and there was just bigger fish
to fry it and I couldn't handle kind of
the stress and the pressure of social
media and the idea of trying to chase a
sunset or make my life look like a
sunset or whatever I was trying to do
and I think the time off was hugely
helpful in kind of re resetting and
figuring out what is it that I really
want to put out there well how do I want
to you know influence people what do I
want to portray
and what I want - yeah what what foot do
I want to put forward in terms of social
media and but I think the break was
really helpful I I think you know more
people if you could do a social media
break and and kind of reset your
batteries I think it's a really helpful
thing to do yeah I feel like we have a
good level of like it's the perfect
level of fame in the sense that we can
be recognized somewhere in Los Angeles
pretty pretty easily but we don't have
like millions of followers because you
know the more followers you have like
the more haters you have the more trolls
you have certainly we get trolled every
once in a while like who knows well when
you call yourselves the minute well when
you call yourselves the minimalists
everything you do become steeped in
irony like I'll be at the grocery store
and I'll have like you know six lemons
in my hand and no joke like this
actually happened this guy came up to me
he's like it's not a very minimalist
amount of lemons you have in your eyes
and you like he was making a joke and it
was it was light-hearted like he wasn't
really actually trying to be a jerk but
yeah well we certainly do like you know
have to deal with that stuff
do you experience a lot of trolls at all
on on social media or I genuinely when I
say I don't check I don't check like I
don't never read the comments because I
wish I wish I didn't get affected by
them but I think sometimes it's easy
it's easy - if you're in a bad mood or
whatever if I start from a kind of
vulnerable place and I check the last
thing I need is to see some Joel bashing
me then I think it's just gonna you know
unravel things I don't I don't recommend
seether like all right I'll read I'll
read Twitter mentions because there are
some really genuine people who want you
know who have a question that I would be
more than happy to answer but like when
it comes to our YouTube videos we have a
lovely lady named Jess Williams who does
all of her social media and she kind of
deals with all the trolls but I
specifically don't do it because it's
like there could be 20 awesome comments
yeah but there's one comment that's like
Brian your hair looks like a mess and
I'm like oh my hair looks like I'm like
and it just takes away from all that
good New Yorker cartoon that we cut out
and had on the podcast it was this this
this guy who was on stage and he was
looking out the audience he had just
finished performing and they're like all
giving him a standing ovation except
there was like one person in the middle
sort of frowning or scalling and now
with his arms crossed
like and he looks out he goes they all
hate me yeah that's kind of what social
media is like so many people are like oh
this is awesome this is great whatever
and then you see that one person and it
will just screw up your whole hour or
afternoon or day yeah and I think that's
because we are brain still treats like
that person's in front of us yeah right
and these are rarely things someone
would say in front of you yeah unless
they had you know some sort of yeah I
mean some of the behavior and I mean
this sincerely some of the behavior on
on social media is like send me autistic
like someone would not only have this in
person but they don't realize like it
we've been given carte blanche our
friend Jamie kill Steen he's a comedian
he's hilarious he just yesterday oh they
were recording this he he put out a
video called how to argue on Twitter
Sean you got to put a link to this in
the show haven't seen it yet if you're
easily offended don't watch it oh my god
it's hilarious
but it's it's obviously it's not
actually how to argue on Twitter but
this is how people argue on Twitter they
get really outraged for no reason at all
they do no research they don't read the
article they read the headline and they
respond to it with massive amounts of
ink or almost immediately and then sort
of wash their hands and you can move on
yeah well a social media is a very it's
a very easy spot for people to express
their anger and and I don't it is partly
because it's anonymous so people will
feel like oh I can go ahead and like
stir the pot here yeah I guess you know
people aren't gonna know exactly who I
am
but there are some people who they're
not anonymous and they'll stir the pot
and then they go to try to get a job
later and then their employers like oh
sorry like 6 months ago you were going
on racist rants we don't really hire
people who who go on racist rants
well and that's a weird thing to about
these the the people who try to call
other people for like these purity tests
I'm sure you heard about the guy in Iowa
who was a journalist who who called out
the guy who raised you see the guy who's
hold up a sign like a football game and
said send me beer money and here's my
Vin mo account number oh yeah he or he
made
three million dollars no way so yeah
here's what he did but here's what he
did he donated all three million to like
this child's charity Doha Children's
Hospital wow that's amazing instead of
keeping the three million dollars but
then this journalist dug up like some
racial racists or semi racist tweets
from him on three five ten years ago and
and it's like okay does that erase the
fact that he did this amazing
okay maybe he said something that was
terrible but he also did something that
was truly amazing
however hmm other people then went and
dug up semi racist tweets the Iowa
journalists found oh my god first of all
like how many people are sending racist
tweets to me one of the things that is
really nice about being well-known or in
the public spotlight is probably better
way to say this is is I feel like I have
to act congruently and and what I mean
by that is like I I act in private not
the same exact way I would in public I
do have a private life but I also
wouldn't be ashamed if if anything from
my private life were to also come out in
public right and it doesn't mean I there
are certainly things like I send some
pictures to my wife that I would don't
want published publicly yeah most of you
don't want to see but I also wouldn't be
like oh I'm so ashamed of that it's just
like well no that's something private
that we share intimately with each other
yeah but there's nothing to be ashamed
balance so living congruently being the
person I want to be both privately and
publicly it is it is I won't say forced
me to do that but it is certainly
encouraged me to live to be a better
version of myself now
yeah I think that with the article we're
gonna get into your article here in a
little bit what we'll talk about because
you were sort of living two different
lives of public life and in a private
life than any sort of hid the shame and
I want to talk a lot about that because
I thought it was it was it was just
amazingly you you shared the story but
you also did so with quite a bit of
humor and I often say that the life's
most difficult or dark or tragic
situations have to be dealt with with
some
bit of humor in order for us to be able
to even digest it otherwise it's so dark
that we can't deal with it that's so I
love that it's articulate so we're gonna
get to that in a moment but first let's
move on to our right lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions to nine three
seven two oh two four six five four
those text messages literally go right
to Ryan's phone and my phone yes it's
really us you are texting us directly we
will answer our favorite questions on
the podcast or will respond to you
directly via text message now just to be
clear we can't answer every question via
text message we've had thousands of them
come in but we've between the two of us
have literally answered thousands of
text messages it's over the last few
weeks it's kind of fun man like I'll
just take an hour and like start
responding to people and say blows their
mind they're like it's just really Ryan
no it's a robot but like semi picture
with a spoon on your head and then only
[Laughter]
we won't respond to as many people as we
can we their answered on the podcast or
we will answer your question directly
via text message and like I said yes
it's really us responded to you 937 to
oh two four six five four what question
do we have right we got a question from
William when will people start to think
deeper about the concept of Fame and
begin to understand it's false promises
well I think this is one of the bigger
problems now is Fame has become the
objective rather than a byproduct yeah
people now often and maybe social media
has enabled this maybe YouTube has
enabled this I actually noticed people
from your generation often speak in
follower counts like I have a couple of
good friends who are Millennials who
like I just had a million followers on
this platform or whatever and I'm like
okay like like ya know like my younger
brothers and sisters who are Millennials
will be like how does it feel to have
you know fifty thousand or seventy
Menomonee Instagram followers what
happen oh how does it feel to have
60,000 s care fellers I'm like does it
feel much different when I had ten
thousand Instagram followers
yeah it's like there is not this this
level of of contentment or happiness now
there there is also but there is this
reinforcement of maybe I am doing
something right but the problem is when
that becomes the outcome I think you're
never going to be happy with it right
because because you you can take your
millions of followers and be like I
can't believe but Kanye West has tens of
millions of followers or you know Kim
Kardashian has hundreds of millions of
followers I'm so inadequate or
incomplete or whatever as opposed to
that being the byproduct of adding value
in some way and so when Ryan and I what
we try to do with this podcast
regardless of whether it gets ten
thousand downloads or ten million
downloads we try to add value and then
ideally what happens is people then
share it follow it download and
subscribe to it for the right reasons as
opposed to the analogy I often think of
is a car crash right people often want
to do something they want to create a
viral moment or something right Ryan and
I have never had anything that's ever
gone viral I'm not opposed to it if
something were to happen great but if
you're seeking sort of virality probably
I think about what that means for a
second viral like it's a virus
we usually it's the only context that we
seek out viruses yeah
in a in a somewhat positive way yeah but
we don't seek out virality but what we
have done is like slowly over the course
of a decade been able to help people
solve problems add value as much as we
can and then people tend to to share the
message and share the story and I find
that the outcome for us has never been
what's the largest possible audience we
yeah yeah I mean if that was the case
dude like we would just do nothing but
home tours I mean like I think some of
our most popular videos on YouTube are
we did some like apartment tours of our
place yes so so like that's that's great
and I'm very happy to get those views
but if we were going off of just numbers
well then we would just start being like
okay what's the next how can we spin the
home to
what other videos can we do that yes yes
yeah and that's the car crash right yeah
so like the problem though is what's
great about that is if someone shows up
for the home tour and then they stay for
all the other things you're like oh wow
they start asking and answering some
real important questions philosophical
questions about what does it mean to
live a meaningful life with less what
are some questions I should ask about my
own consumption etc etc but if we didn't
have that we just had home tours then it
would be constantly trying to get more
clicks or views and it's you're gonna
continue to up the threshold and so yeah
the car crash turns heads but no one
ever stays to watch the car crash they
see the car crash but then they keep
going by looking for the next car crash
right and then what do you guys do next
time well neck one car crash isn't gonna
do it now I have to do something that's
sort of more suffuse 'iv well I imagine
you guys fanbase well maybe being a fan
a huge fan is that it I imagine your
community so loyal and probably probably
much more like when I was getting into
just minimalism in general I want I
tried watching a lot of YouTube videos
on minimalist sand I think what was
really apparent to me was how your guys
intention was really different then what
a lot of other people were doing with
minimalism I felt you know you can just
kind of see the copy and paste this
nature of people's videos and I felt
like the intention the intention with a
lot of people I thought was maybe just
to be trendy or like oh this is a cool
thing that's happening right now so I'm
gonna you know be a minimalist and I
didn't get anything out of out of their
content I felt like okay okay I have a
clean apartment now cool what's next you
know a lot of it is how and I'm okay
with the how everyone knows how to do
you call her there calls the Cheryl
you're like okay I get rid of some of
the clothes I'm not wearing right it's I
donated so okay I've got that but then
what do I feel not just my closet with
but my life with when I and an
understanding not just the how on the
what but the why behind it why is my
life going to be better with less and
what are the benefits for me and and
going a little bit deeper the house
stuff is important and it's sort of a
first step quite often but if you don't
understand why then that calls it will
be
rhe cluttered within a month or two
months or whatever yep the to your point
we do have awesome fans and they are
like super loyal and it's crazy like
when we have these big venues filled up
with people when they leave like the
venue's are typically clean like they're
not leaving their beer cups everywhere
like we have some very quality fans this
is lightning round we try to answer
questions with a short shareable last
140 characters
we coffee and and and we actually paste
our pithy answers in the show notes
they're called minimal Maxim's you can
also find them at minimal Maxim's com
I've got a short pithy answer for you
here - Williams question remember his
question was when will people start to
think deeper about the concept of Fame
and begin to understand it's false
promises and my pithy answer to that is
we often don't want what we think we
want what I mean by that is we don't
understand why we want if often people
think they want to be famous and then
the dog catches the car and they don't
know what to do with him right and
Janette you you had a level of Fame
early on that was probably Hall pretty
difficult to carry yes
yes how do you feel like that you what
did you do cope with that stepping away
from everything I quit acting entirely
because I felt like I needed to do that
and you know earlier I mentioned kind of
the breakdowns of former child stars and
I felt like I was having a private
breakdown and I knew with how the press
was at that time toward me I knew that
all it took was you know one one misstep
and I would just become another one of
those in this story would become very
publicized and it would become just III
I felt that that energy of like oh god
this is going to be a public breakdown I
felt it looming so I just I quit and it
was a hard decision but I felt like I
needed to do it and I think I think it
was really important for me and you know
I I think I needed to completely step
away I don't think that's a case for
everybody you know
but but for me it was I think it's great
like you had the courage to be able to
do that because 11 a lot of people would
just keep plowing through and yeah so my
family thought I was nuts they were like
how can you walk away from this and you
know you're throwing all this away and I
had to deal with kind of their their
judgments and then I was very like you
have very very supportive brothers who
were just so so helpful during that time
that's great instead of carrying it you
can set many things that everything that
you've picked up you can set down
when you like when you think about that
arc that you experienced a Fame yeah I
mean of course hindsight's 2020
is there any like what advice you wish
you would have given yourself like is
there anything that that you can think
of if not no worries kind of put you on
the spot there ya know it's well it's
it's tough because my mom was initially
the person who had wanted me to act and
I do think that's a that's the case for
a lot of child actors is that you know
maybe I think it's more common than not
that maybe they came from a kind of poor
family and maybe there was some pressure
on them to support the family or um so
so in that sense it's hard because it's
not you don't really have a choice I
don't think when when you're a kid and
you've got the the parental pressure and
everything yeah yeah I kind of wasn't up
to you yeah yeah it really wasn't and
you know I was six and my mom put me in
it and was just like you're gonna pay
the bills kid but so so I think by the
time you are you know by the time I was
well shoot because I'm by the time I was
18 I was in these contracts and so it
really didn't feel like it was up to me
either
at that point you know and when you
become 28 or 30 a or 48 it often still
doesn't feel like it's up to you because
we get bogged down by a lot of the
obligations that we think we have to
fulfill we feel the pressure or at least
the pressure we think that is there but
most of that pressure is internal and
maybe there might be some outside forces
that have some unrealistic expectations
but we can also set aside the
unrealistic expectations because you're
never going to be able to fulfill other
people's expectations completely just
look at if you have 500 Facebook friends
Ryan imagine trying to fulfill just all
of their surface-level expectations you
never could even do that
multiply that by a thousand or a million
yeah you can't you you can't fulfill
those expectations and so I think quite
often we need to do is is have better
expectations by having fewer
expectations but also having better
standards for ourself and and for the
longest time from the time you were six
until you were 18 where you didn't have
dominion over your own life you had
other people who were the standard
bearers for you yes and maybe they
weren't making the best decisions for
you yeah and I think I think that's
what's that's what's difficult to think
about what would I have told myself
because I don't I don't know if I even
would have had the wherewithal to be
able to implement anything that I could
have told myself because the choice just
didn't you know feel like it was mine
yeah yeah I wish I could I wish there
was something no no no I think you
covered awhile I mean it's it's a it is
difficult as a child to to do it to make
your own decisions yeah everything is
being forced on you so yeah I mean maybe
there isn't like a solid piece of advice
you can give a six-year-old and you know
I mean that's yeah that's totally
understandable
my pet the answer would be this what
you're chasing isn't as important as why
you're chasing it so you know Fame isn't
bad
I don't think famous is horrible the
problem is is like if you're just
chasing Fame well then you're chasing
the audience you're chasing the
contracts you're chasing the money
you're chasing the followers and like
that is where you start to put aside
living a meaningful life for this fame
that you're chasing so you know I don't
think you and I are famous at all
I mean someone would come up and be like
oh you're famous you're the minimums but
but let's say like it's we have some
level of Fame right let's say we have
some level of Fame like but it is that's
the like you said earlier it's the
byproduct of what we do right so there's
nothing wrong with being famous if
you're someone who wants to be famous
like really sit down and ask yourself
why do you want to be famous if it's
because you have this grandiose plan of
some philanthropic thing that you want
to do in the world then like great chase
it but if you're doing yeah if Fame will
enable you to do some really amazing
things yeah
then go for it yeah but like if you're
just chasing Fame for the the sake of
being famous
well it's you're chasing a sunset it's
funny like I love that Jim Carrey quote
the great philosopher Jim Carrey
he says I wish everyone could become
rich and famous so that they could see
that being rich and famous isn't the
answer to life and it's it's so true and
unfortunately there's a lot of a lot of
I mean this question like what are
people going to realize unfortunately a
lot of people don't realize until a they
either like chase and then they you know
they lose the chase or they actually get
famous but they don't learn until you
know until it's too late so but you know
that's why Josh and I do what we do we
really try to help express what we have
learned through our lives whether it's
chasing the corporate career chasing the
money or whatever it is like trying to
help people see the mistakes that we've
made and hopefully they can learn from
the mistakes that we've done yeah can
you made some mistakes along the way
oh my god yeah so so many me too me too
all right before we dive into our added
value segment and our listener tips
today it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week do you
think that with Fame comes social
responsibility how do you navigate
around the Predators in the business in
Hollywood at what point does Fame become
toxic Jeannette what is your advice to
young people navigate in a world where
personal branding and Fame is becoming
less of a choice and more of an
obligation you know I've noticed that
more and more and more people are
talking about branding themselves isn't
it isn't it like a kids these days like
the number one thing they want to be is
a YouTube influencer yeah in the United
States that's that's true yeah they want
to be a brands we're gonna talk a lot
about that also this tweet from
Jeannette we're gonna talk about I'm
glad my mom died hmm.well wants to dive
deep into that also Jeannette has agreed
to talk about well she wrote this
article about her eating disorder that
she struggled with since age 11 for a
long time and she really opened up about
it and we're going to have her talk
about that and dive into it and I think
it's gonna help a lot of people plus we
got a bunch more questions and things to
talk about with jennette mccurdy and if
you wanna hear all that listen to this
week's maximal episode that's right
you're currently listening to our
minimal apps
but each week Ryan and I and our guests
we record an entirely different much
longer much more personal maximal
episode and let me say this it is
entirely separate endeavor from our
minimal episodes we put this minimal
episode out there it's free its
advertisement free and it helps a lot of
people it's a lot of downloads and we
have a very small audience limited to
six thousand people we're over on
patreon we have the minimalist private
podcast and it's a separate endeavor
they're completely separate episodes
it's not an extended version of this
it's a totally separate Enterprise on
its own and each week we do a maximal
episode now you can get a personal link
to that if you become a supporter and
that personal link or that podcast
episode plays in your favorite podcast
app so you don't have to go to your web
browser and listen on there there are
multiple ways you can listen but you can
also listen on your favorite podcast app
and so you can find all the details to
that it's the best way for us to keep
this podcast 100 percent advertisement
free and you can support us over at the
minimalists comm slash support and with
that you get an additional private
podcast episode every week and plus a
bunch of other things that we do just
for our patreon audience Ryan what else
you got for us this week here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check them out hello my name
is Kenny Hansen and I live in California
I have been a fan of a minimalist for a
few years now and I have been on the
minimalist journey I would say for about
two and a half years almost about three
and recently I ran into a poem that I
thought I call in and share with
listeners it is a poem by Mary Oliver
and it's called storage when I moved
from one house to another there were
many things I had no room for what does
one do I rented a storage space and I
filled it years pass occasionally I went
there and looked in but nothing happened
not a single twinge of heart as I grew
older the things I cared about grew
fewer but were more important hmm so one
day I undid the lock and called the
trash man he took everything
I felt like the little donkey when his
burden is finally lifted things burn
them burn them make a beautiful fire
more room in in your heart for love for
the trees for the birds who own nothing
the reason they can fly and I thought
that this poem was so beautiful and
absolutely the perfect description for
minimalism it is simply making more room
in your life for the things that matter
I think for some people they have a hard
time grasping the purpose of minimalism
and they think of extremists who have a
certain amount of items that they can
have in their life but I think that
that's not it that's not what's being
shared not proselytize but shared by
Joshua and Ryan it's simply it's simply
making room in your life for meaningful
things I hope this tip helps for people
who are having a little bit of a trouble
grasping what minimalism truly is hi
this is Anna I look at Indiana oh I
called to tell you about how I tried to
minimalism thing a while back and when
my mother passed away I got her
belongings so I realized that minimalism
is about getting rid of things that
don't matter and in making room for the
things that do so I'm glad that I
minimalized
what I had and then when a tragedy hit I
could have my mother's belongings her
clothes and a cedra so that's one plus
side about the whole minimalism thing is
that I now treasure what I do have now
than what I did before
all right y'all thanks again to jennette
mccurdy for being with us today and
really opening up and I want to
encourage you to check her out
jennette mccurdy com you can find
everything that she's doing over there
she has a one-woman play that she's
working on it's a sort of musical but
one-woman show where she's onstage she's
writing and directing films right now so
I would encourage you to check her out
the best place to do that is her online
hub jennette mccurdy com will put a link
to that in the show notes and real quick
for right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalist it is a brand new year and a
lot of people have New Year's
resolutions
mm-hmm I know you've resolved to wear
underwear every single day this year no
I actually resolved to not wear
underwear I misread your tweet yeah not
that anyway some people a lot of people
are reaching out to me right now because
I teach a writing class called how to
write better and it's not open
enrollment it's closed for that right
now
but it will be opening up soon but in
the meantime if you want to learn how to
write better I've created a free ebook
that you can download and it's a really
short ebook you can read it in less than
half an hour it's called 11 ways to
write better and you can find that over
at how to write better org that's the
website for my writing class but you can
get the free ebook over there how to
write better org you could download 11
ways to write better you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists and if you
have a question comment or minimalism
tip for our podcast email a voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists comm you
can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
then sign up for our e-mail list over at
the minimalists comm will never send you
a spam or junk or advertisements but we
will send you our simple Sunday emails
each week in addition to our podcast
show notes and for our added value
segment this week Ryan we have the
perfect song since we've been talking
about Fame today one of my favorite
artists I think one of the best writers
of our time is a singer-songwriter named
Jeffrey Foucault and he has a song from
his album horse latitudes the song was
called everybody's famous and it's about
well it's about how all of us are really
trying to to become famous or reach for
that 15 minutes or now 15 seconds of
fame I saw something recently Ryan that
said soon in the future we'll all all of
us will have 15 minutes of not being
famous and we're gonna yearn for that 15
minutes of not being famous to some
extent this is one of my favorite songs
it's called everybody's famous by
Jeffrey Foucault oh and by the way I
just put out a top 10 list well it was
really was top 11 list don't you always
add a couple extra on there sometimes or
maybe I'll remove one they'll be top 9
list some years so for the last decade
I've done my favorite albums
the year so 2019 was a unique year
because I had four number-one albums hmm
so I had a four-way tie for number one
you can find that over at the
minimalists calm slash sound
it's a s arrow it's called the sound of
life but you can find the top eleven
list over there and Jeffrey Foucault has
made that list quite a few years
whenever he puts out an album he tends
to make that that top 10 or top 11 list
but here's everybody's famous from
Jeffrey Foucault and if you leave here
today with just one message we hope
what's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listen y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus
[Laughter]